Game of Thrones is finally on the way
back for its final season promising to
bring answers to all of our questions
about dragons White Walkers and
presumably whether hot pies new
restaurant business was a success still
it's been a while since we visited the
Seven Kingdoms so before we get the
final piece of HBO's epic hit series
here's a quick rundown of everything you
need to know before you watch Game of
Thrones Season 8 the most shattering
reveal of season 7 came in the finale
confirming one of the longest held
theories in all of Game of Thrones
fandom general rule-of-thumb
Stockman don't fare well when they
travel south I'm not a star Jon Snow is
not it turns out the bastard son of Ned
Stark he's actually the son of Rhaegar
Targaryen and Lyanna Stark which makes
him the rightful ish heir to the Iron
Throne as the sister Lyanna was close to
death due to childbirth complications
Ned promised to keep her secret at all
costs lying about John's parentage to
protect his identity not even John knows
he's a Targaryen which is why in true G
ot fashion this reveal was intercut with
shots of John making out with Daenerys
Targaryen his secret aunt surprisingly
that's not the most shocking thing about
the scene instead it's the ramifications
of John having both Targaryen and stark
blood coursing through his veins as we
learned from the three-eyed Raven John's
a walking talking one-man Song of Ice
and Fire with roots that go back to
Robert's rebellion the big brawl in
Westeros that predates the events of the
series Robert Baratheon cut down Rhaegar
on the battlefield and seized the Iron
Throne setting into motion the narrative
we've been following for 7 seasons but
it was all based on a lie
when Lyanna left Robert to run off with
Rhaegar the story throughout the Seven
Kingdoms was that she was kidnapped in
reality though it seems Rhaegar and
Lyanna were deeply in love marrying in
secret just before they met their
ultimate fate Game of Thrones has used
winter is coming as its ominous tagline
since 2011 and season 7 finally
delivered on that promise as the final
image of the season we see the undead
army of White Walkers on horseback
advancing on the Seven Kingdoms the
woefully outmatched remnants of the free
folk and the Nights Watch helplessly
watch as the night king flexes on the
realm
of men by having his new ice dragon huff
puff and blow the wall down that's right
the night king has resurrected an undead
unkillable dragon as the deadliest
weapon in his considerable arsenal so
what's the deal with all the ice zombies
in short whites are the undead hordes of
soldiers who serve the white walkers
former humans turned into zombie like
ice monsters that serve under the night
king the night Kings true motives aren't
yet known but we know that he's
extremely powerful and can control the
entire army with a sort of telepathy
fire can destroy the whites but only
dragon fire dragon glass and Valyrian
steel can kill white walkers Samwell
Tarly has discovered that dragon stone
the historical seat of House Targaryen
is sitting on a mountain of dragon glass
and Jon Snow and his men have been
mining it and turning it into weapons in
preparation ever since as for the night
King it's unclear if anything can stop
him in the third episode of season seven
brand tries to describe the green site
for his sister Sansa telling her that
allows him to see everything everywhere
all at once and also that he can't be
Lord of Winterfell because he's actually
a raven or something like that it's
difficult to explain bear with us for a
moment after nearly being killed back in
season 1 bran has visions and those
visions psychically summoned him to meet
the three-eyed raven north of the wall
and while it's never been officially
confirmed on the show it's implied that
the three-eyed Raven bran meets is
Brynden rivers a former commander of the
Nights Watch he was killed by the night
king in season six though leaving bran
as the last green seer and the new
three-eyed raven the scope and purpose
of brans new powers are yet to be
revealed but any sequence of events that
complicated is undoubtedly going to play
a big part in season eight storyline in
season seven the stark kids have
reunited in Winterfell
Bran's been beyond the wall in search of
the three-eyed raven arya has been
training to become the perfect assassin
with the faceless man before being
forced to escape their clutches
Sansa however hasn't been up to anything
nearly as cool she's been used as a pawn
for years first by the Lannisters and
then in Littlefinger's ongoing
imaginations by the time she becomes the
Lady of Winterfell finally emerging as
the master manipulator instead
of the manipulated pod all three
remaining stark children have been
forever transformed bran dealing with
the burden of near omnipotence has
difficulty relating to his sisters on a
human level Arya and Sansa are
suspicious of each other's motivations
who can blame them for having trust
issues just when it seemed the stark
sisters would succumb to paranoia and
suspicion they got their act together
and teamed up against their truffaut
Littlefinger himself Lord Petyr Baelish
when Sansa called Arya to the Great Hall
at Littlefinger's request it seemed as
though she was going to accuse her
sister but then when Sansa levels our
charges of murder and treason
we got the swerve how do you answer
these charges Lord Baelish Baelish
believed he'd driven a wedge between the
stark sisters but he wasn't counting on
brand filling in the blank parts of the
story that caused the division between
Arya and Sansa Baelish tried to persuade
her that she was mistaken only to be
interrupted by the voice of the
all-seeing three-eyed raven revealing
Littlefinger's betrayal of Ned Stark
way back in season one that was a series
wrap on Lord Baelish as Arya stepped up
and slipped the throat of what was
arguably the most important character in
the narrative of the series thus far the
meeting of the heaviest hitters and the
Seven Kingdoms in the ruin of the dragon
pit at King's Landing in the season 7
finale gave the audience a taste of
where everyone stands in the final
stretch of the great game Cersei Jaime
and Tyrion Lannister euron greyjoy Jon
Snow Daenerys Targaryen a dragon a white
Walker all the major players and key
elements in the struggle for the future
of Westeros were front and center in one
of the most intense non battle sequences
in the series John and Danny hoped to
persuade the Lannisters to at least
temporarily call a truce and focus on
the true enemy the night king and his
army of White Walkers
circe shaken by the exhibition agrees to
the proposed truce on the condition that
john won't take up arms against the
Lannisters alas Jon Snow cannot tell a
lie he rejects Circe's offer saying that
he can't serve two queens seemingly
spoiling any chance of a truce and a
united force to stand against the night
came in Tyrians last interaction with
Queen Cersei in which he hopes to
convince her to take up arms against the
undead army bearing down from the north
he gets sidetracked by daring Cersei to
kill him I'm about to step into a room
with the most murderous woman in the
world who's already tried to kill me
twice that I know of who's an idiot this
is not exactly an uncommon outcome of
the Lannister siblings conversations but
this time it ends when Tyrion breaks the
tense moment by downing several glasses
of wine another common outcome as he
attempts to find common ground with his
sister as the hand of a rival Queen
Cersei reveals that her family is our
only concern and it dawns on Tyrion that
Cersei is pregnant following this
conversation Cersei abruptly declares
that she'll send her armies north to
meet the white Walker threat and
admonishes Tyrion to remember my
kindness of course that kindness comes
with a nefarious plan
Cersei reveals to Jaime her brother and
the father to her unborn child because
that's just how Westeros rolls that she
has conspired with euron greyjoy instead
of retreating to the Iron Islands as
he's led everyone to believe he's
actually sailing to Essos to retrieve
the golden company 20,000 mercenary
soldiers poised to seize and control
Westeros while the armies of the Seven
Kingdoms kill themselves in the north
Jaime however sees the reality of the
White Walkers threat and wants nothing
to do with Circe's double-cross with
Jaime leaving Cersei side knowing the
truth of her plan it should be
interesting to see what he does with
this information in season 8 he's driven
more than anything by his desire to keep
the Seven Kingdoms safe for Cersei and
his unborn child in order to do this
he's got to take up arms against her
cause the audience last sees Jamie in
season seven riding into the unknown as
the winters first snowfall begins in
King's Landing when we last saw
Melisandre the red priestess of ash I
was delivering a very cryptic farewell
on the cliffs of Dragonstone
I've done my part
I've brought ice and fire together
Melisandre worships the Lord of Light
and has shown she is capable of powerful
blood magic though her powers and
relationship to the prophecy prince that
was promised have never been fully
defined her destination is likely the
red temple of volantis home to hundreds
of red priests and priestesses possibly
with power similar to Melisandre Zone
guarded by a thousand man army known as
the fiery hand it's theorized that
Melisandre may return to Westeros in
season eight to tip the balance of power
with her massive army it's worth noting
that in season six Melisandre was
revealed to be hundreds of years old so
it's quite possible that she was in
volantis for the doom of Valyria
the legendary collapse of the advanced
civilization that birthed House
Targaryen in the season 7 finale Tyrion
deduces that Cersei is pregnant the very
next shot is a cut to the dragon pit
original site of the King's Landing
parley one fan theory suggests that at
some point during that time lapse Tyrion
may have struck an agreement with Cersei
to ensure that her unborn child would be
the king or queen to succeed Daenerys
Tyrion believes Dany is unable to have
children but his involvement in this
plot would explain his look of great
concern while listening to John and
Danny engage in some potentially
baby-making behavior later in the finale
another popular theory involving Tyrion
is known as a plus J equals T or Aris
plus Joanna equals Tyrion George RR
Martin's books often mentioned the Mad
King Aerys is lust for Tywin Lannister's
wife Joanna and Joanna died while giving
birth to Tyrion if it's true that Eris
is Tyrians true father it could provide
another reason for Tywin's lifelong
hatred for Tyrion and give a whole new
meaning to Tywin's final words to him
Tyrion has been a fan favorite since the
very first episode so perhaps we'll see
him riding a dragon off into the sunset
to close out this epic tale check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
you